some mistakes will be made along the way
that's good because at least some
decisions are being made along the way
apple is the most successful tech
company in history but what if I told
you that they had a ton of fails that
you most likely don't even know about
well today I'm going to be covering nine
of those and I think you're gonna be
really surprised the first one is Tam
Apple's 20th anniversary Macintosh that
was designed to celebrate the company
and it debuted in 1997 being one of
Johnny Ives first products at Apple now
the TM Had A peculiar design that
featured two both speakers and a really
big Bose satellite subwoofer now we know
that Apple really loves high quality
audio and here they went as far as
giving the Tam a unique startup chime
that you can't find in any other Apple
product
this Mac was powered by a powerpc 603e
processor basically the same one as in
Apple's gaming console which we'll talk
about in just a bit The Tam was intended
to be a luxury item and it had a high
price tag to match this thing was priced
at get this 7 500 which is equivalent to
about 15
000 today making it one of the most
expensive base price macintoshes ever
produced now despite its crazy price tag
The Tam was well received by some
critics for its innovative design and
high quality components one cool thing
is that it had a trackpad built into the
keyboard at the time where almost no
laptops had track pads however the Tam
did not last long and it was
discontinued in 1998 after just one year
of production making it a big failure
for number two if you think Apple
released their first Apple watch in 2015
you are wrong the Apple watch as you
know has been with us closer to 10 years
now out and we now have this beastly
Ultra before the world was introduced to
the idea of a smart watch Apple released
their first Apple watch in 1986. yeah
over 35 years ago while Apple smart
watches are super popular now selling
around 40 million units a year and
bringing Apple more Revenue than Max
this Apple watch is only as smart as the
person wearing it looking classically
elegant with white numbers ringing the
board and the think different slogan
against the black background which is
something that Apple was using to Market
it had a simple clean look but Apple
actually made multiple versions of this
now if you notice that the time
indicators seemed off that is because
the time runs backwards on this thing
they also have the original mac Apple
watch which has Mac OS written across
the band and even this trash can one
which is definitely weird and very rare
as you see you can actually find some of
these to buy on eBay but they will cost
you about the same as a new Apple watch
Modern smartphones have great cameras
with amazing computational photography
features so much so that some people are
asking for apple to make a dedicated
camera but for our next one did you know
that Apple actually made the first
consumer digital camera I honestly had
no idea it was called the quick take and
it was developed in partnership with
Kodak and released by Apple in 1994
being the first affordable digital
camera starting at around 700 bucks the
quick take 100 had a resolution of one
third of a megapixel compared to 48 in
the modern iPhone 14 pro and it could
store up to get this eight photos on its
internal memory the camera had a
built-in flash and can be connected to a
Macintosh computer for image transfer
and for editing now my old friend Gordon
Lang recently did a full video on this
camera showing off the software and the
photos that he took with it which is
amazing that it still works nearly 30
years later now the quality looks really
bad compared to today's cell phone
photos but they did also have a slightly
better version the quick take 150 that
had half a megapixel and stored 16
images as well as some video clips now
quick take helped pave the way for the
digital photography Revolution but
unfortunately these things were not that
successful and apple discontinued it in
1997. for our next failed product a lot
of people have been asking about Apple
creating a dedicated gaming console
there have been rumors about the Apple
TV having a gaming focused version but
what's interesting is that Apple did
already do that and it was called the
Apple Pippin which was a short-lived
gaming console developed in the
mid-1990s now the Pippin was designed to
be a multimedia device that could play
games access the internet and run
educational software it was based on the
powerpc 603 processor which was also
used in The PowerBook 5300 that started
at 2 300 and a version of that chip in
the Tam for 7500 and this console was
only 600 bucks but the problem was that
it competed against established consoles
like the original Sony PlayStation and
the Nintendo 64. it used a CD-ROM drive
like the PlayStation it could run Pippin
games as well as standard CD-ROMs and
the crazy thing is that it had a
built-in 14.4 kilobit per second modem
for internet connectivity back in 1996
where it took Sony until 2001 with the
PlayStation 2 to enable this despite its
innovative features and early support
for some game developers the Pippin
failed mostly because it was super
expensive for gaming console with a
retail price of 600 bucks compared to
200 and 300 for the competitors Apple
sold less than 50 000 Pippins and it was
discontinued a year later so it was a
failure but the crazy thing is that that
even though Apple doesn't have a
dedicated gaming console today last year
they raked in 14.8 billion dollars from
gaming more than most gaming companies
so ended up working out for them and the
next one is the Apple sneaker now in the
80s Apple was trying to get into fashion
complete with baggy sweatshirts
windbreakers patterned shirts polos and
even a children's clothing line they
also were making home accessories like
towels briefcases and more but these did
not sell well Steve Jobs commissioned
the creation of the sneakers and they
were designed to reflect the company's
philosophy of Simplicity and minimalism
with an all-white leather upper white
laces and a rainbow Apple logo on the
side Apple made a handful of Footwear
prototypes with Adidas but the sneakers
were never released to the public people
on the product team did stash a few and
they were also handed out at a national
sales conference and the sneakers since
then have become a collector's item with
some pairs selling for tens of thousands
of dollars at auctions if you'd like a
pair you can actually get a perfect like
new set for fifty thousand dollars from
Sotheby's or bid on a pier for twenty
four thousand on uncrate but personally
if you really want to pair I would get a
replica for 450 bucks for our next
failed product we have the Apple TV
Apple's been rumored to be working on a
TV set for many years now but other than
some leaks we don't have any concrete
evidence however the company actually
did produce a TV set of sorts in 1993
called the Macintosh TV which was a
computer that could be used as both a
computer monitor and a cable ready
television the Macintosh TV used a
14-inch Sony Trinitron CRT display and
as a result the included credit card
size remote could be used to control
Sony's TVs as well only 10 000 were made
and they were based on the Macintosh LC
520 that had a black design it was an
all-in-one design and powered by a
fairly weak processor 5 megabytes of RAM
and a 160 megabyte hard drive it had a
CD drive and a built-in TV tuner so you
just watch TV on it now I recently
reviewed the Samsung Smart monitor same
thing with the LG one and this is a
really cool concept so it's great to see
apple doing something like this way back
then it was marketed as a high-end
product and it had a premium price tag
of two thousand one hundred dollars
however it did not sell well and it was
a failure being discontinued just a few
months after it hit the market mostly
because of the high price tag speaking
of displays that is what our next fail
is in the last 10 or so years displays
have been very boring very similar most
of them looking the same but in 2023 we
have this LG display that has a unique
interesting layout and some people
really like it but did you know that in
the early 1990s Apple released the
Macintosh portrait display which was
designed to be use with a Mac and it had
a unique vertical orientation that
allowed for more efficient use of space
this thing had a 15 inch display with a
resolution of
640x870 pixels and that was actually
high for the day and its display was
actually black and white but it used an
active Matrix LCD that was new tech
which provided for sharper and clearer
images compared to passive Matrix and
the very interesting thing is that today
we are still using that Tech now the
Macintosh portrait display was
discontinued in 1993 along with the
Macintosh computer that it was designed
to be used with unfortunately this thing
failed quickly being discontinued in
1993. now just like the Apple watch if
you think Apple released the first iPad
in 2010 you would be wrong because
before that they had the next fail the
message pad this thing was a personal
digital assistant or PDA which was
developed and produced by Apple in the
90s it was part of the Newton platform
which was was a series of pdas designed
to compete with devices like the Palm
Pilot the first message pad was released
in 1993 it had a six inch black and
white touchscreen display and it had
Innovative handwriting recognition
software which was a major selling point
so it allowed users to write on the
screen with a stylus and have their
handwriting converted to digital text
while this thing received massive
Fanfare during its launch and up being a
massive failure being regarded as
another high-tech expensive but useless
device because the handwriting
recognition software did not work very
well which led to a lot of criticism
despite its initial success the message
pad lineup was eventually discontinued
in 1998 however this device paved the
way for future mobile devices and it
influenced the design of the iPod and
the iPhone and later on the iPad Apple's
next failed product is a device that I
think would be cool to recreate today it
was called the e-mate 300 which was kind
of like a mix between a touchscreen
tablet with pen support and a MacBook
with a keyboard now this was ideal for
classrooms just like many costumes today
where the iPad is ideal combined with a
keyboard case add a durable outer case
and it had a long lasting 20 hours of
battery life which I wish we had in our
iPads the e-mail 300 was released in
1997 it was powered by a 25 megahertz
arm processor shout out to Apple silicon
and had one megabyte of RAM and 2
megabytes of flash memory which just
sounds crazy in today's specs it was
designed to be rugged and portable and
had built-in software for educational
use such as word processing spreadsheets
and drying programs now the e-mate 300
could be used with a variety of
peripherals including a modem a printer
and an external keyboard despite its
unique design and the educational Focus
the eme300 was a fail for apple and it
was discontinued in 1998. now some
Educators and retro computing enthusia
you still have good memories of this
thing because of its durability and the
Innovative design but prices haven't
really gone up for this vintage product
and you can buy one right now for about
a hundred bucks on eBay so go and check
one of those out so there you guys go
there are nine failed Apple products
that a lot of us especially younger
people like myself had no idea existed
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments section below click that Circle
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I will see you in the
next one
[Music]
thank you